Ashi Kohli is a motorcycle mechanic in
Pakistan he works in an area where
owning a car or motorcycle is out of
reach for some residents but a sheikh
found a way that he could help for the
last 10 years he's been giving rides on
the back of his motorcycle to anyone who
needs one for free
many are stuck Turkish is a group in
India you see I wasn't on the Navy and
they come with optical on the trophy a
Billiken
we'll be monitored by Joe's
disappearance of rice Chex you know
parashah me I can walk with khalaby hey
mahadji scindia's army is a somebody get
me a rod may convince New Year's Day
possible to school my poor mama with a
little jabbers over Jordan
it to egg him on a Billy Cusimano tear
makisi when I'm kissing a car my name is
he al Carrera moment why be there I do
you push your one is super bottled up
deliver what meant but at first people
were skeptical to gain their trust a
sheiks best friends a far gave him the
idea to play recordings of the Quran
from his bike now the two friends ride
together picking up passengers wherever
they go
but upon my school portada e2 /
politically iced tea - ma / - seriously
gilja
Miska bodies keep on our arkovich need
solution solution
you know just call me later Jeremy
tomorrow jaga Bob see tomodea I was a to
assuage as a Jeremy's kokanee satiric
countyman I exit over
agonal apartment mozzie Bujji organize
kebab on Adia - inshallah ma'am or
better cook
no problem guys come timing but on the
medicine
you